hello everyone I'm a lot of welcome to
play watch listen we are currently
weekly to try to bring you some
light-hearted entertainment during the
tough times naturally I am joined by
video game composer Austin wintry game
actor Troy Baker yeah and video game
director Mike Biffle how's everyone
doing oh did you do what yours more
sincerely than awesome I went for like
me like the the boy bands like in GTA 5
I mean there are plenty anyway you can
do it you can choose like a pose for
when you win and that that's how they're
animated in life I was always that yeah
it was always that one yeah because it
affords yeah i miss GTA like that that i
do leave my my xbox and play i think we
talked about this before like i from
we're gonna get it this later based on
the top of you pickle on it but I went
from xbox 360 to Xbox one and then the
servers went to [ __ ] and so then I went
over to PlayStation and then I've like
started over like had to start my rank
all over like three or four times
there's a big ass beating I still play
that game every week what do you do you
do the races or dudes what do you do
because of fun house we have we do
weekly GTA I host it so I actually
played GTA probably like four hours a
week because I test maps so we do like
races Oh death matches a Last Man
Standing most of which are custom made
because we've already done all the
previously built ones so I just like
troll through custom made Maps which the
community still makes crazy stuff all
the time yeah I recently found this guy
who goes by sip on the Rockstar social
club who basically makes these challenge
maps that are like just stupidly hard to
finish like it's really hard to figure
out where to go they have puzzles that
you'd never figure out and they just
races like stunt races but then just
like Super Meat Boy style like
challenging platforming nonsense and
they're super fonts but then yeah we
stream GTA once a week to so I know what
did you see my thing were the heists
like I I love the - OH
much but then I'm also the guy that that
literally the remember the day that I
figured out that you could if you stole
a car or in your car whatever and you
went underneath the overpass for the air
force base and you did the u-turn and
you hit the ramp at just the right speed
just the right angle you could jump over
it immediately go to five stars and then
you could go into the hangar steal a jet
and then it was just rain Hellfire down
on everybody and it was so great it felt
like playing vice city where you're like
somebody figured out that you you can't
really fly in the plane but if you like
did the whole hyperbaric bubble and you
just kind of let yourself do that you
can stay up for a while it felt like
calling back to those days and then cuz
when they in GTA 4 when they let you is
like oh here's a plane you could fly as
like fun anymore the whole point of that
game was to break it yeah one of the
hottest missions in San Andreas to me
was always the the first one when you
have to fly a plane because the controls
are just so bad and I think at the end
of the game one of the loud emissions is
you're controlling a toy plane which is
also really hard it's like just he did
that in by City though - you did with
the Burt Reynolds missions you went up
and had to blow up the the big
construction site or whatever and you
did that devastating we had a city where
at a certain point in the game maybe
eight hours and I would fall through the
map no matter what I did so I never
played it again oh wait a minute you
didn't finish it you didn't get to the
finish three I finished San Andreas
because they were all in this boxset
when they came to xbox and vice city was
in that too but I could just never
finish that game but I did I think it
did come with the soundtrack like all
the different stations on different CDs
so if I say it's amazing did you
actually do a remaster of Vice City is
that a remaster is just re-release for
do I could just imagine like if they did
vice city as a remaster uh they've got
the money
or just another game set in that here I
mean it was bad with media Rockstar play
it was intended to be Scarface the game
right like it was awesome cig you didn't
get to the Scarface but we're in that
you come out and you it's the whole big
shootout it's like oh it's so great it's
funny I I there's like three GTA's in a
row that I just full-on have never
played I've never played san andreas
hands up never place it in a dress never
play Ballad of Gay Tony that's not
everyone talks about that dick those are
their definitive was like three four was
kind of I just didn't like Niko Bellic I
didn't care like oh no no and I also I
also didn't like I understood his
position like this there was a big
article that came out after that thing
dropped this wildly successful game and
then the actor cameras name plate Niko
Bellic was like I only made a hundred
grand off that game and at that time it
was like yo homie that's not a good look
on you and it just never worked again
because it was like yeah you also just
made a hundred grand of that yeah
exactly it's pretty hard to privative
Lee sure but it's like what he was
trying to do is coming from as a film
actor he was like or TV I always get
residuals I'm like that's not games
that's there's not a structure for this
and game studios are not and like we can
get in this conversation know for sure
structure for that because I mean that
game was at the time the best selling
game of all time GTA 5 is now and I've
also heard that Rockstar haven't played
very kindly with the voice cost of GTA 5
know should that be a residual so let's
let's play that yes because for how many
how people are thinking I'm gonna be on
the opposite side of this but for every
read Debra Densham Grand Theft Auto 5
Call of Duty effects Legends fortnight
there are a litany of games that barely
ship and so if there is a structure
that's put into place that says here is
a mandate now I remember when the the
strike happened it was
for games that sell I think it was there
there they said their breakeven was like
250,000 units I was like you're out of
your mind it's when infamous second son
shipped their breakeven and I hope I'm
not telling tales out of school but
their breakeven was like they needed to
sell three million to break-even was
that very expensive game and at that
time you had 7 million ps4 users because
it was essentially a launch title and
when it did its opening week it sold two
and a half I think it did two and a half
or three and a half million copies I was
like so you didn't capture 50% of your
market share and there's no other
competition
like it was it was a it was a it was a
big wake up call because clearly the
game was successful clearly the game was
good but it's still like when there's
nothing else out there there's still
some people that aren't just going to
immediately buy that game they're gonna
buy the Call of Duty's they're gonna buy
the GTA s they're gonna buy the red
Dead's whether they play them or not red
debra Dench is like where the lowest
completionist rates ever but you didn't
even finish g device city for different
reasons it's a wildly successful game so
my thing is this if we put a mandate in
place yes
does that tap the people like Rockstar
yes but that is one developer out of
scores that would literally what it
would end up happening is they would
scope their game and they would hire
less actors so less people would work so
it actually goes out against what people
wanted to actually do or they would just
or they would just like get a call from
their legal department saying no no
Union talent of any kind you know and
they would just they would just
composers have gone through this similar
because we have we have all the same
parallel considerations but without the
leverage that actors have so we had to
give this stuff up ages ago because in
the film world similarly there is
residuals that come through the
performance royalty associations like
ASCAP and BMI and SESAC in the US PRS
and the UK it said
and these these are organizations that
collect royalties for composers on for
secondary market income so it's like
generally speaking so like if I score a
movie and it plays on TV later it's not
it's not structurally about the
secondary market it's just kind of how
it works out in practical terms if it
plays on TV later every one of those
performances is considered a public
performance and so every play on TV
rather so I'll get royalties and part of
that is that if you score you know a
movie like like okay my the composer I
used to share a studio with John Debney
scored one of his earliest scores was
the movie hocus pocus which every year
gets like a little rebirth you know and
there's like a little mini sort of let's
all watch how his focus he also did elf
which happens also the same oh wow named
whim and so and so it's like every time
it plays on TV he'll make you know
potentially money and it's all it's all
weighted based on these formulas based
on like is it on a major network in
primetime versus an esoteric cable show
is that right in Flex blah blah blah
blah blah and the the thing that I think
there's no real there's no real parallel
to any of that in in games like you said
you sell the game once and for most
people that's it that's the only time
the developers ever gonna make money I
know that the the P ro societies are
trying to explore the idea that twitch
could be a comparable thing to a TV
airplane because if someone's dreams
your game they're making money off of it
there yeah so it's like there is
potentially market there obviously it
would be a fraction of the size of like
Spotify scenario Austin sorry in that
scenario the the idea is that the
streamer would pay the composer is that
what you're saying well the the weight
like the way it works if it was to be an
exact duplicate of like the television
model for example NBC and so in this
case twitch play pays an annual license
block
ASCAP and then they basically say here's
all the movies I showed here's all the
TV shows that we did and you also as the
composer have to send in your cue sheets
because those things can also be
subdivided you know like if I if I
co-write a cue like a main title cue on
a show
there's writers there's performers
publishing there's all sorts yeah
exactly so it starts to get super
granular eyes but yes and so it's a it's
a pretty big task and there's a [ __ ] ton
of money I mean both both ASCAP and BMI
pull in over a billion dollars a year in
these licenses and they're both grown
nonprofits that that are just turning
around and paying the vast majority this
was it like I we're doing stuff for
retro replay I was trying to figure out
like how can we cuz I wanted to do like
we did a podcast and we we're gonna in
the episode with a song it's like here's
a song that hit me today and this is
these arms by paper kites whatever and I
wanted to end the podcast with that song
PJ Haar's manager Lewis are two
producing printers right dude you
actually can do we have to be so much
money for that it's like Dewey so I
called a bass cap and I called it BMI I
was like hey just curious like if I
wanted and I chose this specific song I
was like what would that be it was like
five hundred dollars I went oh so it's
five hundred bucks to season one I guess
no no no no it's five hundred bucks a
year and you can use anything you want I
went what if I want to use like Elton
Johnny goes 500 bucks for the year I was
like so that's how like I get stuff for
that the music that I've put up and if
it goes on YouTube if it goes anything
else every Thursday I get a thing from
TuneCore that says hey you made seventy
three cents or whatever so that's coming
off that five hundred bucks that whoever
pays it was like but if it's used again
for a commercial or if it's used for a
film or something else that big library
because I mean one of the biggest issues
with making content on YouTube is that
you often can't use licensed music for
example I don't know if you guys know
but if the YouTube channel gets three
strikes a strike this on a copyright
takedown a strike is like I'm much more
serious like a fence if you get three
strikes your channel is removed
IGN got its first strike while I was
working there because somebody used a
Drake song and that was enough to keep
the channel
strike it was just well d monetizing
this we literally got strikes you cannot
use a Drake song in a YouTube video and
every video on my channel that has ever
been demonetised has always been because
of music including video game music I
had a heavy rain playthrough was the
first thing I ever recorded it's so bad
that it's so old but all of that got do
you monetize because of the music in the
game as well claiming that yeah yeah
sometimes it's a mistake it's automated
that's the thing that sucks it's not
even someone going after you it's
literally just like an algorithm
music I probably won't say which project
it is but I always upload little
snippets of things to like SoundCloud
and one of them got blocked before it
even uploaded and it was lie and I wrote
and I said I'm the composer I have the
permission of the publisher and they
were like yeah we it's just like there's
a standing block from that publisher but
then what do you pay what do I is the
content creator as the channel owner
what do I pay ASCAP and BMI for I don't
really know like that's the fuss that
iPod that you can do that because at
funhouse overs two teeth in general we
do have a music library that we pay to
use but none of it is like popularly
licensed music it's still a really cool
asset for us and we use it all the time
it's and the one that we use
specifically like you can search like I
want it to sound electronic and I wanted
to have this kind of fender I want
vocals and you could be very specific so
finding stuff for background music is
really really helpful for that but in
terms of using licensed music we just
absolutely can't do it
in some cases you can't even sing
because if they somehow recognize the
notes that you're singing it can get a
copyright takedown basically but I've
also had videos get copyright strikes
because someone else on YouTube some
other youtuber did a playthrough of a
game and then their management team
decided to copyright everything that
they had done and the algorithm thought
they were cooperating every part of that
gameplay rather than just that person's
exact video so they've just accidentally
taken over entire video games we had
that were Thomas was the lone tonsils
lone has like a generative soundtrack so
it basically it's randomized generative
over state
but it's randomized the in terms of
which particles in a runtime and we had
someone claimed ownership of like a
minute of it under a certain
circumstance and we got to find out
exactly how repeating that soundtrack
was because about one in a hundred
YouTube videos at Thomas was alone got
struck by this it was a really
interesting test of the concept lot to
find out how well we don't know exactly
that is is it you two just kind of
covering their ass is that what it is so
they don't get going because there's
actually no real copyright infringement
that's happening or what is that yes
does everything is like you know right
now virtually any video that has any
mention of coronavirus is just
immediately having no ad revenue because
that I guess worried that some
advertisers aren't going to like being
associated with that because it's right
now it's considered political it's like
just stuff like that they just blanket
destroy everyone in hopes of protecting
themselves really I mean it's it's a
mega cool but as well which causes the
problems like if they actually had like
moderation staff who were making smart
human decisions they'd be fine it's
because you in some cases but really but
I used to use a song from a producer
called moon who some of you might know
from the hotline Miami soundtrack and I
had reached out to him and been like can
I use this particular song as a backing
track for my youtube videos and he said
yes and I had his permission but YouTube
still took it all down and then I would
fight them on it basically and be like I
have his permission in writing but they
were like there's no option for you to
include a screenshot or a document or
anything when you give them your
rebuttal so just like well I don't know
why I'm asking
like in Austin's case when you're
literally the composer yeah what's so
funny is on a daily basis I get an
noticed from Instagram saying that a
video of yours has been taken down due
to copyright infringement you something
you there's a part of your video where
you may not own it and you stick Graham
Instagram and then I goes you're after a
further review your your video has been
reposted
and there's a video that you have that
should be taking that and it's a daily
thing where I get to put back up and
it's from Warner Brothers music I guess
which holds the that specific copyright
or publishing for the recording of the
Austin you would know it's like I
inclined something it's it's a eine
kleine Nachtmusik yeah it's it's like
it's some piece of Beethoven that I did
a video when I was walking through a
city in Switzerland I was like oh this
is a beautiful and I just did this great
thing look how good I am with an iPhone
total Brinton just like a director in a
European town and is like guys you can't
use that like it's me on holiday man
what I got to find the video and you'll
know exactly I'm talking about the
tickets very sorry no no I always I you
know I think a lot of this is because
we're still in the kind of growth pains
of this medium that that a lot of the
legal structure is built around it took
you know took a hundred years to really
work out how radio TV movie theaters
you know DVD how all of those are
interconnected and and and how you know
people can make the most possible money
if you know their content like their
their movie studios movie or whatever is
being heavily heavily consumed like
figure out the channels and the Internet
can close all that apart pretty suddenly
and so you have like 90 years worth of
infrastructure that is suddenly trying
to pivot in like 50 directions at once
and just struggling because yeah to me
to me the fact that like if your video
on youtube has five seconds of copy
written music and it will just it will
defer the whole videos ad revenue over
to the publisher of that piece I'm like
we've got to get more sophisticated in
our handling of this because I don't
think any reasonable and the majority of
youtubers and channels like roosterteeth
and and funhouse and IGN and all these
big channels plus all the smaller
youtubers I don't think any of them are
doing anything you could religious
scribe is stealing yeah no one has any
problem with the idea that like if
there's a hundred dollars on the table
and I used something that that somebody
else owns and and like if a few dollars
of that gets siphoned off towards that
person like I don't think anybody is
gonna have any issue with that it's the
idea that it either just gets shut down
outright or the whole hundred dollars
suddenly gets gets redirect it is also
just that's so strange
the benefit to budding artists that
would like hey I broke because someone
did this YouTube video that that
featured my my song to me it's it's it's
crippling to the end that this is what
I'm talking about I understand
in theory the philosophy behind
protecting artists but in the interest
of this just like with video games in
the interest of doing that you actually
hinder the further advancement for for
everybody oh for sure I want to know a
story about that actually so I do in
Journey came out I remember when when
when journey came out the because the
game has no dialogue or sound effects
that I mean there is there's a lot of
actually really great sound design by by
Steve Johnson but it's it's largely
subtle the music does a lot of the audio
heavy lifting so it's like a silent film
in many in many ways and so Genova the
creative director had this thought right
before it launched we were planning on
releasing the album you know day and
date which is normal but Genova goes if
someone were to listen to this album
before they play the game it's kind of a
spoiler of the games emotional
experience and that's all the pain is is
an emotional experience so he goes we
should wait to release the album for
like two weeks until after the game has
been out it's the only time I've ever
done this and so so we did and and then
the funny thing that happened was like
the game came out obviously it had this
pretty outrageous response and people
were immediately asking for the album
and some people figured out ways to kind
of rip it out of the game and started
posting it on YouTube before the
official album had been released and I
had never seen people like ravenously
trying to get my music before this I
mean I you know three people maybe when
Flo came out a few years before that but
not really to this extent I mean
videos just instantaneously had tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
hits from ripped game files like
immediately so I went on all that all
the uploads I could find and left the
comment that was like hey I'm Austin I
wrote this and I just I am thank you so
much for sharing it because like it's so
it's so touching to me and then one day
I wake up after a couple days of that
and someone messages me and says hey
have you gone on reddit today and
literally on this is the one exception
because literally on the home page of
Reddit like not even in the sort of
gaming subreddit or something like that
on the front page
somebody had noticed that I was doing
this and screenshot in a bunch of them
and made like a collage and said
composer sees his music on YouTube and
does and doesn't react like a little
[ __ ] that was their caption bow-wow so
of course I comment on that and it led
to a kind of an impromptu AMA and and
the thing just you know it had like
thousands of uploads and [ __ ] and so
then and everyone just was shocked that
I was and I was like why would I no one
no one is sharing it because they are
like this modern you know blue beard
pirate who thinks that they're like
romantically or like or like or Robin
Hood you know like yeah and and so then
the crazy thing was that when the album
like so many people said well this is so
cool you know I I you know I will buy
this on iTunes or whatever when it when
it comes out properly because like they
felt so good about that interaction and
when and the thing came out it [ __ ]
charted higher on the Billboard charts
than any video game soundtrack ever had
before and it was like you see what
happens when you when you kind of open
armed approach people and say I see
where you are
I get that you're just trying to think
share stuff you think is cool and like
as the person who was involved in making
that that's really touching and so these
draconian systems that are like
no no it's much better to just not allow
it than to like explore the nuance to me
it's it's baffling and it's a massive
opportunity they do make you all look
like All Souls because people are gonna
assume that's what the composer wanted
which is an interesting point I mean I
imagine it's coming from the
corporations but I know with Nintendo
and Konami particularly there are a lot
of restrictions for what kind of game
play you can upload on YouTube
I know Nintendo was relaxed but I had
back when I was working for a network
show in Australia we had videos that we
put on YouTube get D monetize for even 5
seconds of a Pokemon trailer it was just
a nightmare and you'd be like why do you
not want to work with us and then they
started this program well you could give
them I think it was automatically 30% of
Ben Atlas who make persona had streaming
restrictions on persona 5 where if you
got to a certain part in the game they
would automatically D monetize you and
in some cases also flag your channel so
that would be like getting a strike on a
Twitter stream or whatever which was
done with the intention of removing
spoilers rather than because they just
wanted to profit off of people playing
the game it's this really complicated
thing and I mean Mike I feel like a
really good person asks a question how
do you feel about Let's Plays in streams
where your games are concerned I know
the shooting who made that dragon cancer
so that they think that Let's Plays
dramatically negatively impacted their
sales really yeah I can sympathize with
that position like I kind of I get it if
your game is predominantly a as I think
that game is and this is definitely our
criticism but it's predominantly like an
audio visual storytelling thing and you
can get 95% of the experience of playing
it via watching a youtube video which is
I presume their argument for that
perspective perspective they were very
like we had a I remember we released
subsurface circular and Quarantine
circular kinda just after that and I
think some similar kind of stories and
we we we have the same kind of concern
in
totally of like because subsurface
circular frame watching this is not
seeing it like it's a basically like a
dialogue tree the game it's not it's a
Mass Effect dialogue tree but for like
an hour and a half then with like not as
much production value and we were like
quick I'm a brilliant pitchman I'm like
it's true but like the we had the fair
we were like this is this is something
where you could watch a video of this
especially with a youtuber because the
game doesn't have voiceover it's
entirely text-based like if it's an
interesting youtuber who's doing like
voices and stuff there's a chance this
is actually essentially more
entertaining and storytelling on YouTube
so we had that kind of internal
conversation like they were gonna like
literally add value to it and therefore
you know maybe you watched on you don't
bother to pick up the game what our
decision was was when you load up either
of those games there's like a little
button on the main menu and you can
click the saying like youtubers and
streamers if you click on that it
basically takes you to a page which is
like hey thanks so it's similar to
Austin was posting on those those
comments like hey thank you so much for
wanting team and consider sharing our
stuff we're really grateful to them for
liking it enough um if you do please tag
the videos spoiler if you're going to
show the ending because both of those
games kind of have twist endings and
kind of we didn't want that kind of
getting around too much and also like
you'd be doing us a massive favor if you
only shared kind of the first half of
the game so people want to go and check
out more just very transparently kind of
laying out this entire concern but at
the same time if you choose to put it
all up there thanks so much for your
support and you're cool and we're not
pissed off of you basically was what
this thing it was like five paragraphs I
think and we have similar thing I mean
not the same scale as you Austin but we
had like reddit threads about like wow
developer like straight-up telling us
exactly what their concerns are and a
lot armen people having responded well
to that I mean most of the videos of
those games literally start with them
booting up that disclaimer and
describing a all of the messaging in
here and saying hey this is what the
developer feels and then half the cases
they say we want to play the whole thing
so we're going to we're going to let you
know before we start that they want to
kind of yeah they want you to experience
it this way so if you want to switch off
something most of them even say like you
want to switch off the video halfway
through feel free that's the spirit of
the video we're all sharing you I just
created a nice I think that's it
it's amazing from people like grown-ups
people like like old straightforward
honest common people in PR can sometimes
forget and I understand hi to that the
people who are streaming and making
YouTube videos who and not the
traditional media they used to dealing
with generally just really love video
games they generally just really want to
share these things with the audience and
the minute they get an email from
someone at a publisher they're gonna be
like oh my god but there's two sent me
an email I can tell everyone but there's
a sent me an email and asked for this
I'm absolutely gonna comply cuz they're
so excited to be a part of it it's not
that they just want to make money and
burn to the ground ninety five ninety
five percent of people are decent people
we should walk through life with that
presumption I think I be prepared for
the five percent but don't build your
entire life and plan around the five
percent I I think it's also critical to
be inclusive into for lack of better
word assimilate rather than to distance
and punish and seek to try to police
people it's like hey how can we bring
you in and actually support the people
that are out there pirating things the
radio ahead is is famously been the ones
that have always done this like we're
just gonna put our album out for free
and if you want to buy it great do it
when they did I think it was held if
I've never listened to the album like
it's there of my motto is was one of
them to my knowledge is one of the
primary investors in Apple like like
she's right it's super super early he's
the first billionaire musician and you
what you want about that man
but he has perpetually perineal II tried
to make this world a better place
whether you agree with them or not
whether you like his style or not
the man has objectively devoted his life
to philanthropy
well how many K tqx does he weigh
you're gonna pick up a South Park
reference he's the biggest dude or he's
the biggest turd ever made as South Park
said but that was just a little moment
for Austin and I but the to be able to
say hey we they have had a long history
like they were the first ones on iTunes
so I don't know if anybody remembers
that I know they were the first artists
on iTunes no way yeah they were that win
when Steve Jobs launched it and there's
a whole I wish I could find this article
Steve Jobs said it with a tremendous
amount of irony that this his comment
didn't necessarily age well but somebody
asked him is like are you just trying to
make money off of music and he says no
I'm trying to solve a problem within the
music industry right now because if
people have no legal option of how to
get something that they desperately want
you cannot hold him accountable for
stealing it I was like yeah he goes so
something what's that song we pay $1
sure and someone said are you trying to
create a new revenue stream he goes we
have three billion dollars in the bank
do you really think I care about making
money off this and he really didn't and
the the irony of that is that lo and
behold iTunes became the number one
revenue stream it gave her to the App
Store everything else it became the
number one thing for Apple as a company
to where they also make you know
computers but they they had their own
YouTube had their own iPod they had they
they were the one that started the whole
red thing so I mean they have a
long-standing history and then all of a
sudden they're like we're gonna give you
our new album the thing that I applaud
you to for constantly doing is the fact
that they will put out [ __ ] and they
will own it there's a song called always
that very few people know because it was
a single that they put out and they
pulled it back and they rereleased it as
a song called a
brand new day right because the original
song was like always wear your safety
vest always it's terrible it is awful
but they did a fully produced version of
it a beautiful day not branding a
beautiful day and then they were like
what if we pulled this song back and
retweet it and then put it back out
again is a much much better song so the
thing that I think everybody hated about
it was not that they've forced you to
listen to this album is a four she
listened to that album because it's not
a good it's kind of a [ __ ] u2 album
which every once in a while they they do
so but that that that's also something
slightly invasive about about like this
will come on your phone and you can't
get rid of it I mean my issue was that I
always shuffle my music and it was
shuffling to music that I did not want
to listen to okay that's not my love
song that was just weird we've finally
relitigate seing this most pressing this
is the most pressing issue in the games
industry right now I'm glad we were here
for it I'm glad we beat a button Austin
because I remember well it my final
thought on the whole you YouTube
copyright strikes and all the rest of it
I can't remember we'd mentioned this
before as part of our kind of roundup of
2019 but I remember when I first fired
up control I did what I always do and go
through and like adjust settings and the
menus and [ __ ] before I even play the
game and I just happened oh and I'm
always curious what controls they give
you in especially in terms of audio
remix thing it's just one of those as it
moves just a professional curiosity
how-how-how kind of specific or or or
granular they'll make it and I saw
something in controls menu I had never
seen before that was clearly a response
to everything that we're talking about
which was there was a box you could tick
that said click here to mute any copy
written music
so remedy have had that in their games I
think since Alan Wake really famous
famous I believe Alan wakes Alan Wake
has loads of life as you say like
there's definitely there was in the
licenses like run out so well no as I
remember Alan Wake got pulled off a
steam because spired I feel like I feel
like Alan Wake was one of the first to
do that I remember noticing in our lake
and thinking exactly what you're saying
basically at the moment where YouTube
side this is I mean this is why remedy I
love that the world's finally waking up
to remedy being amazing as like Anna
remedy apologists forever good stay like
is just kind of going like compressions
a solid sound like depression I was
gonna ask you guys as people who have
made stuff that I think has been
emotionally impactful I think all three
of you have how do you feel about
watching a content creator or someone
react to something that you've made life
what is that like like watching someone
have an emotional response to a game
think you've worked on who's gonna go
first like take it away like I say I
absolutely know it's cool I totally kind
of if I see people often tag me and if
it's Thomas was alone as the one that
people still kind of are always lets
playing and they'll often tag me and if
it's like a livestream I'll sometimes
kind of jump in and kind of watch and do
like a Q&A that's always fun but you
know I really I'm just amazed anyone
plays my stuff still like that's just
always the overwhelming thing of me for
me it's like this person I've not met is
aware a lot of Thomas was alone it's the
the thing I I found myself doing the
other day for something I was actually
using the wiki for one of my games like
the fan made kind of encyclopedia things
to check a fact about script I wrote a
few years ago like what was the name of
the I'm not gonna say what it was what
was the name of this thing I had in this
other game and I was checking that so
I'm I'm always just blown away to people
play stuff let alone like
that's a reason so humble but that's
genuinely true no make sense I mean you
know one of the nice things about
scoring a game is that it's really easy
to it's not it's easy to not fall for
the delusion that you know I made this
game and so I get to when I watch like a
let's play I it's the it's kind of the
closest thing I get to being an actual
player of the game where I get to
vicariously feed off of their reaction
because coming at it from the inside
I've never been able to play journey or
Abzu or the banner saga or whatever as a
player in in reacting earnestly because
I too much on the inside so I get to
have the closest possible approximation
of just being a player of that game
while watching someone play it and I
like that a lot it's it's fun it's it's
a way because they'll do stuff
differently than me it's like their
thumbs just don't do the things that my
thumbs would do and so I see things from
a perspective that even after a thousand
hours of play test during development I
somehow never saw exactly that way and
that to me is it's just so cool but the
the closest kind of like the the thing
that's unique about my little corner of
this is that when someone's really
engaged and really loved it
they'll make their own covers of the
music and that to me is the that's the
most astonishing that's that's where
I'll say all the same things that Mike
just said it it blows my mind that
people like it at all but that someone
would then go to the work to the trouble
of like learning the music and in most
cases they have to do it by ear and then
you know sometimes they're so elaborate
and sometimes like I remember I wrote
all these songs with my tripod pals for
Assassin's Creed syndicate and like
there's this cut there's multiple
Russian youtubers that have done Russian
translations of those songs with like
fairly elaborate production value and
stuff nice and like it's just the crazy
sick so I i periodically will go and
search on youtube to see if there's some
of
those that never that guy never got
tagged or no one ever shared because
it's my favorite thing ever to go and
comment on those videos and say even if
it's because some of them they have like
five hits you know like it's something
that's just totally undiscovered and and
I love it's it's I get so much joy going
to those people and being like you have
no idea what it means to me that you did
this because that's just there's no
greater validation I think than
stimulating someone else's creativity
especially when they make it totally
different than originally wanted and
they're not making it for your attention
or your approval or to get a job they're
just passionately creating something
that you happen to find and I love that
both of you have said that that you go
and you comment on these people's stuff
because my hundred-percent which I guess
is similar like fan art for me is the
thing that just blows my mind that
something that we made is now something
that someone again would sit down with
some with in some cases it's like a kid
thing I remember one I remember doing a
talker school where one of the tutors
one of the teachers of the school
brought over like their eight-year-old
had made me had written me a letter
about their idea of what the thomas was
alone sequel should be so it was like
you know a year old kind of by row and
they'd laminated it because laminating
something makes it shows that it's
important yeah it laminated the whole
plastic it was just like the sweetest
thing they completely threw me off the
talk I was maybe giving at this
university but like it was that stuff is
just yeah it's mind-blowing did you
respond with a letter from your lawyer
saying Biffle game so I actually I was
gonna leave this out the story because
again it makes it sound like a
self-serving [ __ ] feel-good story but
like literally I've made the two I
didn't make I asked the the the mother
to bring a she had like how the paper I
was like or a pen and I actually wrote a
response letter kind of complimenting
the kid on the ideas they've had and
which yeah that's awesome that's how
about you Troy I imagine there's a whole
lot of people playing stuff that you've
made it is always I I kind of resonate
with what both Mike and Austin said it
is the closest that I can get to having
experience from the inside to be able to
look at it from the outside to see what
it has meant
and especially with something like The
Last of Us I remember asking Neil we
were on stage and we're discussing the
last scene and I asked him I was like
aren't you afraid that people are gonna
hate this and this is right in the
aftermath of while we were shooting that
was when Mass Effect 3 came out and
there was that whole fallout and I think
we've talked about this before he said I
don't care if people love it or hate it
I just don't want that to be ambivalent
and to me that is what I love is did we
have impact everything that all of us
are in some ways I've said this before
all of us are storytellers and by then
proxy all of us are artists and we're
creating art and the thing that I have
learned is that I don't create art for
that to serve me I don't write a song or
create a performance so that I feel
better so that I feel like I was a
tremendous musician or a wonderful actor
or a great writer or a great director if
I do that I will perpetually find myself
dissatisfied disappointed and
disillusioned with my own abilities
never enough never never enough so and
what I do is I say there's literally
something that I'm working on right now
and Austin knows this to where I'm
starting with something and it is
literally the seed my art that I can
create is one part of it and what I'm
hoping is that we can put this out and
Austin does this as well put this out
there and I want you to make this better
can you make this bigger better faster
stronger more impactful and that to me
is watching someone's reaction video
that is my that becomes my art that's
what serves me is that when I see
someone do those like it mattered it had
impact that is that is the art that
serves me and so that's that's all that
I try to do did you watch like people's
reactions to like the lost was pot to
reveal trailer and stuff like that dude
there was nothing III will never be able
to
explain or describe this feeling so
we're at PSX and they had we were
sequestered like they wouldn't let
Ashley or I anywhere in public view we
had to come in separately
especially Ashley they had her like come
around the back I got there super early
so no one was there if I was there it's
kind of like Oh Troy's here at Tori's at
some PlayStation thing but if Ashley's
there that's like red flags so they had
like coming under hoodie and everything
and straight up to our hotel room so
that no one could see us and same thing
backstage and like walked separately and
then they kept us backstage and then
they showed the trailer and as they
started the trailers like could we
finally go sit down and they're like yes
cuz we've been standing back there for
hours and so finally was like we're
making our way in the dark as the
trailer is playing and so we're walking
past from the back all of the people
that are lined up that are actually in
attendance in the hall and so you see
people watching the screen and then they
go and it's like it was that moment with
Han Solo it's like it's all real and
people were crying cuz we're passing and
we're like you know walking like moses
christ ok and we get to watch this thing
the fruition of what we have been
waiting for and working on for so long
and then that is reflected in the eyes
of the people that were watching it and
i don't know which was more this was
more impactful for me so yeah that's
that's that was probably the greatest
reaction i've ever seen was when people
who had been holding onto hope finally
get to see a glimpse of it saying it's
it's real what what we've been hoping
for is real and I don't know if I'll
ever have that moment again yeah I
remember not probably know quite as cool
I don't know one of the but those two
press conferences recently maybe two
years ago now the Deb's off today
finished that finished the presentation
then mics was still hot and they were
like we killed that and I was like I'm
so glad that we still hope that because
you know that those people are not like
trained public speakers that a very
interesting thing about the games
industry is that games
a very long time to make so for but the
bulk of that time nobody has any idea
what you're working on no I can't even
talk about what you're doing and then
one day suddenly you can and then you're
allowed to say whatever you want like
Sean vanaman who was one of the writers
on half-life Alex had to be really quiet
for a while until they announced that
that team at Campo Santo went over to it
and then it was negatively received even
though Sean who was felt very positively
about getting to work on half-life unity
loves half-life is now tweeting and
being like I'm so happy this thing is
out and I get to talk about it in the
hall while just really enjoying that
game because oh my god it's incredible
but you only get that moment for a month
and then you go back to silence again
yeah especially when someone else's
secret cause like in the indie space
like you're keeping secrets but no one
cares like no one's like it's not it's
not like the last first thing where
people are like speculating or wondering
what the next thing we're making is but
then you end up directing a John wick
game and you can't tell anyone for a
year and a half and it's so that was
that was the worst especially everyone
on this call knows how much for show off
I am like I really want to tell all the
time it's boring but like the amount of
the amount of times I almost told
someone and then sometimes where I
absolutely did tell someone I'm weird I
do believe though that there are certain
people in this industry and Mike you are
one of them where at least people who
are privy and savvy to this industry go
I wonder when Michael's gonna make
another game I wonder what what game
Lucas Pope is working on I wonder why
carry coins put me on this list that's
that's a very generous Lucas as well
like I mean we do beyond deafening on
that level Lucas Lucas is incredible
like da genius but I think those are the
true and there's people that I'm sure we
could go in and add to this list as much
as we want to but there
that is is Kojima being is like it's a
Hideo Kojima game in hadiya's doing
another game so III do think that this
industry has those auteur feels like a
appropriated word not an appropriate
word necessarily but appropriated word
because I don't know if that applies
because an auteur evokes a certain kind
of context that I don't think of my we
talked about this before mic that it
barely applies there's no Orson Welles
unless you're Lucas Pope there's no
Orson Welles in the video game industry
there's just a you or someone that is
constantly and lifting up and showcasing
your team it is that's very kind of you
say it's it's somebody I think that's
honest as well I don't think I mean my
pro hi Archie I'm prom without a theory
across the board because there's never I
mean short of like novelist and
singer-songwriter there are very few
artistic Toby Fox one of the only ones
in the game industry that I could name
whose Toby Fox the guy that made
undertale did everything himself
that's I think we I think it's I think
it's the responsibility of people who
are elevated in that way by the press
it's that classic Warren Spector joke
right where the article is Warren
Spector commenting on people people are
always too fast to credit one person on
its game team says Warren Spector
brackets thief Deus Ex it's that cliche
of like yeah I know I'm in a weird
position as well because we called named
the company after me because they
because my name became so kind of
strongly associated with Tom Sloan that
literally people on the team were
telling me like we have to name the
company after you because no one has
heard of whatever stupid company name
you wanna come up with now so we kind of
I mean this weird situation where I'm
the guy yelling about how our theory is
[ __ ] while having a company named
after myself which is that interestingly
hypocritical position yeah titular or
the eponymous is not necessarily
synonymous with being
tor I don't think nobody can be kind of
self celebratory in a way that I find
not good has been this is great I'm
saving so money in my so much money on
psychiatry right now pretty sure
doki-doki
literature club was also made by one
person but it's mostly the one person
which is dan salvato but then also he
had two artists as well like that's a
game that won a ton of awards that did
something very unique that was made by a
very very small group of people and I
love hearing those stories as well which
is obviously design notice like people
who single-handedly made games I have a
friend who's working on a sort of
stealth sim right now that he's been
working on for about six years and it's
just him nobody else and I love seeing
that stuff because I personally like
always want to work with a team I don't
like doing things independently really
because I feel like I love learning from
other people and that's just a personal
thing but someone who can make a video
game by themselves and make something
that's that impressive is just it's so
cool to see for anyone who doesn't have
access to a big city or access to other
people in the industry that they can
jump into I don't know I'll PG make ax
or whatever it is the dev see using
these days to just make something really
cool and that's part of like one of the
things that I hope we kind of get out of
this period of time where everyone's
stuck at home is just I can't really see
so many interesting things like I don't
know many people who have the ability
and opportunity to do something weird so
on like I'm specifically doing something
completely new that I've never done
before I know most people seem to be
like I think a lot of people are seeing
as a long side obviously the horrific
reality of the situation like are using
the opportunity to do something kind of
different it's about breaking them out
making all of our routines and our
patterns right which and is creatively
great my superfans a [ __ ] though oh yeah
bed at five am and then had to wake up
at 9:30 for a conference that I had to
cover that was supposed to be a preview
event but they moved it digital which is
like a really interesting part of how
this is working for media is that they
through discord live streamed the
conference and had the dev speak over
what we were seeing in discord that's
how they're doing preview events now
because interesting Hanson yeah
then recorded this and I'm gonna go back
to sleep I'm actually really I'm
actually really interested let's dig in
on max that sounds that's a completely
different way of doing preview events
how did you find out like what was the
what was that like for you and what did
you think it was what did seem like it
was like for the developers like give us
some more insight max that's that's new
I think that that's how preview events
are probably going to go forward for the
next three six twelve months I don't
know is that we're going to have to see
them as live streams it worked pretty
well on discord this almost put together
by private division who organized didn't
honestly very well I don't want to mean
from Terra burn OPR who shout out very
good company thanks everybody oh yeah it
was everyone on a discord server you'd
all be invited in only the four I
believe for devs and and a PR rep were
speaking over a presentation they were
live-streaming to us polity was really
bad so they were trying to show us
gameplay because it had to be live
streamed through discord it looks like
crap which means they have to tell us it
looks like crap I promise it's really
pretty which is a really tough thing to
situation and that's not fun yeah but I
think I love previews previews have
always been my favorite thing to write
in the games industry in pot because you
don't have to get all critical and
analytical with it you can be fun about
it range as a developer as well there it
so it's a nice time reading I had to
write my Mass Effect Andromeda preview
it was one of the hardest things I've
ever had to do because I was like I
didn't like it and the gamers are gonna
hate me for not liking it because before
this point nobody has said a bad word
about this game so I was like I'm just
gonna write facts I'm just gonna write
the objective facts and no opinion was a
menu where you can lower the volume it's
pretty much exactly what I did
there is a character creation menu that
appears to be extensive I did say that I
thought the faces look like The Sims 3
not even The Sims 4 which was probably
the harshest thing I said but it's still
prudent to get back to how preview
that's working another thing that I
didn't like about it is I loved being in
the room when a preview was happening
and being able to throw a developer a
question and
have them like show you what talk to you
really candidly and like one of the best
preview experience I've ever had was the
first time I saw dreams which i think
was in 2015 2014
at Paris games week and I just kept
meeting like what can you do this and
were like yeah and I was like could I
make this and they're like yeah it was
like how about this and I just kept
trying like I feel I could I make a song
can I make Guitar Hero can I make an RPG
can I make an MMO and they kept saying
yes yes yes yes yes and it's that
experience of just being there and
watching them be like excited about the
fact that I'm excited about the fact
that there was nothing they said no to
you know one of the only things they
ever said no to me on where dreams is
concerned is that the driving music they
didn't think that they could have
characters that could would fall like it
and they were like we don't think it
would work in that game what we think we
can only have two legged characters
people figured it out it's it's so cool
but basically it's yeah that's what they
called them quadrupeds like we don't
think we can make them people have made
them in the a function perfectly but
losing that from a preview is like you
love seeing devs be excited when I saw
Baldus k3 recently and the cinematics
are so pretty and they're watching all
of us intentionally staring and all of
us while the cinematic is happening not
looking at the projector behind them so
they can watch people for the first time
see their stuff losing that is a huge
bummer I feel like it's just like gotta
be much less motivating for those teams
that now they're just giving it an info
dump on a discord server where we're all
muted and we don't want to ask any
questions or react audibly so that we're
not interrupting anyone else on the
discord service so I think it's taken
like just that one is it was efficient
but I feel like it took a lot of their
like love and passion that a developer
could have expressed out of that
happening and I think that will probably
hurt a lot of pre DS for the next six 12
months
yeah it they also had a Q&A segment
afterwards but again because everyone's
on discord you can't see when someone
else is trying to ask a question just
not a lot of people ask questions which
maybe it's just the thing that it will
take us some time to figure out but for
now yeah that that's one aspect of media
that I never thought about that I'm sure
during e3 is gonna be a really weird
ride well my hope is if you look at for
my sins I really like
some like American late-night TV hosts I
really enjoy like I'm Seth Meyers and
stuff I'm watching all of them like
leave work and the first couple of like
they're all doing doing some of their
segments and have show parts like from
their living rooms watching the first
episode where it's like on their webcam
like cameras like this because they
really know what's going on and like and
the jokes aren't landing because they've
got actually no audience to KO these are
guys who like their entire experience is
working in front of a crowd of 300
people 400 people so then see in
literally the course of the week now
those have become hyper polished you
know they worked out the cameras like
they're there at like a level where
they're on a par with like you on a bad
day along there right like man they're
like a bear like a like a week youtuber
now they're like a audience but that
bothered me and I was I yeah that was
not good at all they were obviously the
team was trying but like it's worrying
and troubling that was that was that was
the point where for me this thing almost
veered into like bands environmentalist
dopey whole thing yeah I went I went I
went to the supermarket the other the
other night and in the UK were on
lockdown it's essential trips and
fitness only um so and I'm going to like
the supermarket like once a week getting
a shop getting back just basically
minimizing our choosing same here in LA
right you guys I haven't left in a week
I was not we're excited I know you Mary
Kurtz it varies from state to state
presumably yeah I don't think it's
enforced by the police it's more likely
reinforced by the police San Francisco
is I imagine we'll be there any minute
now
well bluntly hopefully probably give him
a sense but the UM the the but though
the weird thing was just going into the
supermarket and like literally on the
newspaper there's a newspaper on the
floor that said something like it didn't
say the end is nigh but it said
something like it knows it was a
pandemic hits crisis point with like a
newspaper billowing in the wind
movie right now this is just this is
terrible some of that's interesting that
way so one of my I don't know if I've
ever really even spoken about this
publicly because it like it's not
something I think will happen but my
post games media goal for a really long
time was to be a late-night talk-show
host and I specifically wanted to do it
because I used to watch a lot of
late-night talk-show hosts and I
specifically wanted to do it for like
instead of just Hollywood stuff
specifically for nod stuff so someone
else would have some other actor on I
would specifically have video game
actors okay I'm directors or whatever
but still have like late-night talk-show
hosts you're in the dream like I did
stand-up intentionally with the plan of
like leading into that happening and
like exploring that whole thing is like
a thing that I'm like yeah maybe I'll do
eventually but in my head it's always
been like but women can't do it and oh
but TV will probably be dead by then and
like I had all these like things in my
head that would deterrence and I'm like
I should take a look at how go and watch
like this Hulk show hosts trying to do
your job and see how much they're
struggling I think you've probably it'll
be good for you to see that like I think
yeah I think it definitely demystifies
this there's a lot of magic that happens
when someone's on a stage with snow it's
so much easier special be funny when
there's a crowd writers by the way truly
be engaging when you're streaming by
yourself is not something that's easy to
do and I feel like I self and catch
myself like playing a game that's
difficult and not wanting to be bad
because then people will be angry at you
for being bad but at the same time
trying to answer complicated questions
and have coherent sentences and I don't
think people realize how hard that is
so you I saw you apologizing for
downgrading the difficulty on doing the
other day and I just thought along it's
got completely different I said I play
easy do all the way to doesn't have
higher difficulty I love hard doom but
there are loads of games that have been
easy like time for people like my
questions when you're trying to maintain
it like a conversation with your
audience as well I can't imagine it
really is
I got a lot of [ __ ] when we were doing
our playthrough of the Last of Us
because there's what people to
understand that there's so much that's
happening and
the studio that we were at because
there's lights and there's everything
else that's happening it was super hard
to see the screen
I've got production in one ear I've got
Nolan and the other I've got drew that's
calling out stuff just less I was like
guys we're almost at 45 minutes when you
start kind of like looking at breaking
this up and I'm like trying trying to do
this and it's been three years since I
played the game and so it's not fresh to
my memory but it's I think the beauty of
this right now is what I'm seeing happen
is by and large there is a level of
forgiveness and understanding that that
people have and lower production value
it there's there's more of a connection
and a resonance one-to-one because it's
like okay you're doing the same thing I
am it felt weird to see someone's still
in a big production like hey you're
supposed to be home right now what are
you doing
life isn't normal right now so if I see
something that isn't normal life it's
actually died act or not didactic it's a
it's off-putting for me so I flew there
arts of dissonance there we are again
[Laughter]
because they shot Mandalorian inside in
a small room right there so it still
technically make that show just a couple
spots on set every episode all running
it out loud and it's just the
Mandalorian just looking around
throwing a virus can transfer to baby
Yoda that's that's the scientific
consensus right now I apologize for
giving bad advice please look okay this
is the Internet you guys let's level of
integrity it sounds like a lot is
wrapping us up next week thank you
joining me I hope everyone's doing well
and everyone who's watching back home is
doing well
yeah like I said we're weekly every
Friday for the next little while or as
long as our schedules allow for I'll
keep everyone updated
I'm Alanna Pierce thank you for joining
me Austin Troy and Mike we'll see you
guys next time
all right bye